hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar multi-omics approach to
understanding PDL one resistance in
cancer i am michelle ashton of blabbers
and all your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminar is presented
by lab roots and brought to you by Sony
biotechnology to learn more about our
sponsor
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
active we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want and anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into that ask for question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation this presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window to all the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speakers dr. Moshe
se Feldman the instructor in medicine
and the director of the translational
cancer immunology lab at the
Massachusetts General Hospital Cancer
Center and dr. Russell Jenkins assistant
professor and member of the faculty of
medicine at the Massachusetts General
Hospital Cancer Center for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Feldman and after Jenkins
will now begin their presentations
Thank You Michelle for this kind
introduction
and here are disclosures so I'll first
start with a quick background on
checkpoint bouquet therapies I'll start
with the how and why so how those type
of therapy is actually work so
checkpoint therapies actually take
advantage of the natural process of
t-cell activation
and whenever it is or gets activated in
response to stimulation could be cancer
it could be infection there's an
appellation of inhibitory receptors on
the cell surface of those cells and this
actually controls the amount of
activation of the cells preventing them
for over activating and eventually a
phenomena that can lead to tissue damage
and autonomic disorders and the way that
checkpoint therapies work they actually
block the co inhibitory receptors and by
doing so they're unleashing pre-existing
immune responses of the t-cells
against the tumor cells one thing we
need to know about checkpoint therapies
that these therapies actually depend on
the ability of cytotoxic cd8 t-cells to
recognize new antigens that are
expressed on the cell surface of the
tumor cells in the context of class 1
presentation so what's so unique about
checkpoint therapy so checkpoint therapy
have succeeded where conventional
therapies have failed and if we in terms
of inducing more durable responses in a
wide variety of metastatic disease
effect that eventually led to the rapid
approval of these drugs in wide variety
of cancers in recent years with melanoma
being the first one in 2011 however
although if even if we take melanoma
that has one of the highest mutation
rates still most of the patients and do
not respond to those therapies and those
who do respond eventually relapse within
the first year and a half and the main
question that we ask ourselves what
actually drives tumor to escape from
checkpoint therapy why some patients
respond and why is some patients do not
respond to therapy and in recent years
there's been extensive research trying
to answer those questions and when we
look what are actually the drivers or
mechanisms or factors that are
associated with either response or like
a response
we can actually break it into two so the
upper part talks about what we may call
the acquired resistance patient that
have an initial response to therapy but
after a wild day relapse and the tumour
progresses and patients if we look at
the lower part these are the primary
resistance tumors these are tumors that
do not respond to tumor add to these
types of therapy this could be due to
lack of infiltrating or targeting T
cells within the tumors or defects that
are already present within the tumors
prior to therapy such as loss of antigen
presentation capabilities if you look at
the upper part so what actually drives
the response so we know that tumor
mutational burden the more mutations the
tumor have the more targets they have
for the immune system to recognize we
need a functional immune system in those
tumors most likely dendritic cells that
can present those antigens to the tumor
to the T cells we needed T cells that
are has a cytotoxic functional
functionality that can actually
recognize those tumors but then when we
have these kind of responses these
responses as I mentioned are usually
limited in time and eventually there's a
relapse in most of the cases and again
this could be due to acquired mutations
that the tumors have acquired that
enabled him to evade immune destruction
or the detection of the tumor by the
immune system or by generating or
altering the immune system by generating
more tumor supporting micro environments
such as the up regulation of additional
Cohen hibbett or receptors or the
attraction of suppressive cells that can
actually suppress the activity of the
cytotoxic cd8 t-cells however if we look
at those studies there are those studies
that have been done and within here have
major limitations first of all they have
a low predictive power for instance if
we take tumor mutation burden as a
standard that has been evaluated in many
types of cancer so if we compare the how
how good is Team B in our ability to
separate between
they're more likely to respond we see
that there is a big overlap between
patients who respond and have a low
tumor mutational burden versus patient
who do not respond and have a high tumor
patient burden and we see that there's a
big overlap and many states studies you
can actually cannot separate between the
responders or patients that will benefit
in terms of survival by using those
specific markers the other limitation is
the usage of predefined immune markers
that that actually limits our ability to
identify new factors that can actually
actually elect an immune response or
associated with either successful
failures of those therapies the surge of
bulk RNA seek data that pretty much
limits our ability to infer specific
cellular states or markers in specific
cells or the contribution of specific
cells as we are looking at an average of
expression within a given tumor another
specific expression within specific
cells and again I think the other
limitation that was that most of the
studies that were using unbiased
approaches before in recent years
actually focused mostly in the tumor
cells but pretty much ignored the
microenvironment or the immune system
which is also crucial for the success of
these types of therapies
so what's their point that we decided to
take so as the title mentioned we do use
a multi omics unbiased approach to
actually answer the question we don't
start with the specific hypothesis we
start with the problem that we have in
this case is patients melanoma patients
that are treated with checkpoint therapy
we have the patients that respond
patients who do not respond and now we
want to find why some respond to therapy
while others do not respond so actually
the the way the approach that we take is
being broken into two steps the first
step is the discovery phase when we use
really both genomic and transcriptomic
unbiased approaches to discover the
landscape of immune cells within those
tumors once you identified and classify
those immune cell States and cells we
identify which one of them has actually
associated with a clinical outcome the
second part is the validation phase so
once we identify either a cell or
specific gene that is associated with a
clinical outcome then we start to build
our hypothesis and then we
experimentally check them this could be
done by using a everybo system in visual
system and other functional assay
as I mentioned some of the patients that
are treated with checkpoint therapy
respond but the majority of patients do
not respond and our major question was
why some patients respond to therapy and
why some patients do not and we decide
to focus on melanoma and the approach
that we apply for that was using
single-cell RNA sequencing so the court
in general that we analyzed was composed
of 32 patients and as you can see here
in the upper right part it actually
breaks the cohort and distribution we
had 31 non-responding lesions that were
taken from patients that were treated
with checkpoint therapy we had 17
responding lesions lesions that were
taken at baseline on treatment and we
also had 11 patients that had much Prien
on therapy samples the way that we did
this type of study we got a fresh
biopsies from the clip from the surgery
operation room with the rapidly
dissociated the samples we isolated the
immune cells using a cell sorter and
then it performed the single-cell RNA
sequencing using the smart stick to
protocol that is a full-length protocol
that has the best coverage in terms of
single cell methods today we also
incorporate this with other methods
looking at the genomic level to see
whether there's mutations that can also
interfere with the immune tumor
interaction such as loss of class one
presentation capabilities in the
interferon gamma pathways and eventually
we performed an integrated analysis to
incorporate all those parameters perform
validation experiments and associated
everything with the clinical outcomes
two things that I would like to
emphasize or move on is that why do we
actually need it to sort the cells and
why do single cell approaches and are
better than the bulk approaches is so
single and enables us actually as I
mentioned earlier to look at specific
transcript within individual cells and
to look at specific pathways within
individual cells to look at the
compositions of those tumors and how
those cells relay
to clinical outcomes and again unlike
single-cell RNA sequencing bulk RNA
sequencing gives us only the average of
what's happening in the tumor and we
cannot infer the states or specific
genes within individual cell and the
example that I show here below actually
showed that there's been several
research talking about specific genes
that are associated with clinical
outcome but then when we look at those
genes and their Association for instance
with CD 3 that reflects the CD in the T
cell infiltration within to within those
tumors we see that there's a very high
correlation between those genes that
actually the genes that we see by using
bout RNA seek are usually correlated
with the amount of or the degree of
infiltration of a specific immune cells
and in melanoma is mostly P cells so in
that correction when we look at or use
bulk RNA seek data and as I think one of
the main limitations you will see
transcript that belong to a specific
cell if this cell is highly abundant
within the tumor a limitation for single
cell so single cell is a very good
method but it has a limitation that we
need to recognize it's more noisier than
the bulk earning stick there and that's
due to technical limitations and bio
biological factors there's more
heterogeneity also single cell and I
knocked bulk RNA seek has a higher
dropout rate and a lower capture
efficiency so not all the time we will
capture all transcripts within a given
cell the second part which is to the
right why do we actually need to sort
and this is very important because not
the quality the quality of the sample is
not even among all patients sometimes
the sample is very necrotic and the
amount of viable cells within a given
tumor is very very low as you can see
here in the upper left corner so when we
start the sword we actually have the
ability even if we are given a tumor
with very low viability we can actually
focus on the good viable cells and by
using or excluding a lot dead markers
another thing that we incorporate into
our soul sorting is the usage of the CD
2 3 5
a marker and the reason that we did that
we noticed that especially it's relevant
when we look at the tumor side that
there's a lot of ossified progenitors
that are reading the tumor and these are
cells that are usually cd45 negative and
the lower plots actually shows you that
when you what happens in a tumor that
you have a lot of those cells so you
will see those cells of cd45 - but then
when you look at their class 1
expression which is the one of the
hallmark markers of red blood cells and
red blood cells progenitors they do not
have any class 1 in molecules so that's
actually also to distinguish between
those populations of cells that
eventually their RNA content is minimal
and eventually the quality that we get
from the sequencing is very bad if we
integrate those into the tumors they can
also falsify or give us negative and
results in terms of that we might think
that we're getting on the city 45
negative cells which is mostly the tumor
compartment and then we might think okay
these tumors are lacking class 1
expression but they're actually not
because we are getting on this very
dominant population of erythrocytes
progenitor so this is one additional
thing that really help us to distinguish
the good and the bad cells and actually
making sure that we are getting or the
right populations so as I mentioned in
the two previous slides before we decide
to focus our efforts on the melanoma
court of patient written checkpoint
therapy we initially use the single-cell
RNA approach to in an unbiased way to
define the moon landscape in melanoma
patients so by doing this type of
analysis when ended up with eleven
clusters by using an unbiased caming
clustering approach and we ended up with
two Bissel clusters two married clusters
and the make the remaining clusters the
seven remaining clusters were mostly
composed of lymphocytes at different
cellular states and the next question
that we want to ask yourself which one
of those cell cell types and states are
actually associated with clinical
outcome and when performing this type of
analysis we saw that there were actually
six clusters associated with bad or good
clinical outcome we saw that if the
basal cluster was said with a it was
more enriching the responder compartment
the to malate cluster more enriched
significant rich in the non-responders
and three clusters that were mostly
composed of cdat s of one of them
reflecting a memory and phenotype was
most enriching the responders and two
clusters that were mostly associated
with this election and dysfunctional and
phenotypes were enriched in the
non-responders tumors
now since the mote the majority of cells
identified within our course was more
mostly cd8 t-cells and due to the fact
that we know that cd8 t-cells are
crucial for the success of checkpoint
therapies and that three of the clusters
that were either associated with
response or lack of response are mostly
rich for CDT so we decided to focus the
rest of our analysis on this cell
compartment so we started by focusing
with the city in typical part man and we
started very unbiased analysis by
breaking the cd8 t-cells into two
clusters and we end up with what we call
the cd8 B the bed cluster that's mostly
enriched with exhaustion markers and
markers that are usually linked to this
functionality of the cells and the
second cluster was the cd8 G cluster the
blue cluster that was mostly rich for
self-renewal genes and genes that are
mostly associated with stemness and
memory of cd8 t-cells and the first
thing that we want to ask yourself how
those two seller states associated with
the clinical outcomes the one we looked
at the responders we see that there is a
significant enrichment for the cd8 good
the good cluster the cluster those
associated with memory cells and when we
look at non-responder this we see that
there is a significant enrichment for
the bed cluster interestly when we look
at patients we don't see that the
responders have only the bed cells or
the cd8 be the ones that are
dysfunctional and the responder have
cells that are only the good class of
the memory itself we say that there's a
causation
of those two population however we see
that in most cases in non-responders we
see an enrichment for the dysfunctional
cells and in responders we've seen
enrichment for the good cells the memory
like cells and the upper plots actually
show you a patient who initially
responded to therapy and after a year
develop resistors and at the time of
resistance we see there's actually a
switch within those two cell or those
states now since we saw that those two
several states coexist together in
patients that are treated with
checkpoint therapy we decide to
calculate the ratio between the cd8 good
the memory cluster versus the cd8 B the
dysfunctional cluster and when looking
at all samples or at baseline samples
prior to therapy or on treatment we
usually see that in most cases patients
who do response to therapy have a higher
proportion of those cd8 g-good cluster
cells versus the cd8 B the dysfunctional
t-cells when we can take into account
the whole spectrum of ratios we usually
see that a ratio above 1 meaning that
there's more of the good clusters is a
very predictive marker and very good
predictive marker of the clinical
outcome in this case is the clinical
response to checkpoint therapy in
melanoma patients sort of thing that we
want to do after we identify cell types
and link them to clinical outcome we
want to see whether could we can
actually identify predictive single
markers that are linked to response and
we looked at all cells and within cd8
t-cells we ended up with a list of
markets that were either enriched in
responders or genes single genes that
were actually a associated with lack of
response and then we asked ourselves can
we actually take one of those genes or
that we identified a and predict the
clinical outcome in an independent court
using a method that's more applicable to
the clinic so we decided to focus on TCS
7 because this gene was one of the top
genes that was associated with response
we're looking at all cells over looking
specifically within the cd8 t-cells it
was also one of the most highly
differential expressed genes within the
8j cluster which is the memory light
cluster so what is TC f7 or
transcription factor 7 it's part of the
wind signal pathway in the context of
the immune system this gene has been
shown to be crucial for the self renewal
and differentiation of hammock biotic
stem cell it has also been shown in
recent years to be crucial for the
reintegration of cd8 t-cells in response
to checkpoint therapy in the context of
mouse chronic CMV in mouse models so the
approach that we took was using a more
pathology like approach using a amount
of fluorescence standing on FFPE
sections so again we collected an
independent cause of patients you have
the break here a total of 43 samples we
had 23 responders 29 a story 23
non-responders 20 responders and the
idea was to stain 40 cf7 within cd8
t-cells because this is where we saw the
gene to be associated with response
within ctcf 17d cells within CTC f7 to
be significantly enriched in manual we
saw this gene to be significantly
associated with response when it's
expressed in cd8 t-cells so we took this
approach we stay in the section we
developed a pipeline using the so
profiler algorithm that actually enables
us to quantify the number of cd8 t-cells
that are either positive or negative 47
in an unbiased way and when we perform
this type of analysis similar to what we
did when looking at the single sore and
sick data we saw the cd8 pieces that are
positive for the CF seven are
significant in which in responders and
tumors that actually do not respond to
therapy or more and meet for cd8 t-cells
that are lacking t CF 7 similar to the
single-cell RNA seek data we see again
that these two populations of the TCS
positive and negative cd8 cells coexist
in responders and non-responders within
their responders we see a usually a
higher proportion of those positive
cells for TCS 7 into non-response
receive usually a negative again similar
to the single cell we calculated the
ratio of those two populations
we looked at all samples based on sample
on treatment samples and again we see
that we can actually predict the
clinical outcome by looking at those two
power methods in addition to the
clinical outcome we see that in most
patients that are and have a higher
proportion of those cells they also have
a better outcomes in terms of the
clinical survival the next thing that we
want to do once we perform this type of
analysis is to identify them they the
identity and functionality of those
specific cells and Sellers things so
I'll spit up a little bit the talk here
so we took the cd8 t-cell compartment as
I mentioned we're starting with a very
simple analysis by breaking them into
two classes but when we dived in a
little better and perform additional
Mouse's eventually the cd8 G and the cd8
B broke into three clusters each so we
have three different clusters of a
t-cell exhaustion or dysfunctionality
and we ended up with the cd8 G with
three clusters that represents three
different cellular states of T cell
activation and memory what this type of
analysis actually enable us to do it was
to identify a specific cell surface
markers that can actually enables us to
pull out those specific cells from
either human or Mouse tumors and test
their functionality so when we perform
this type of analysis or when we pull
those cells out again using cell sorting
approaches we compare the the isolated
cells that we identified by the social
surface markers to the original
single-cell RNA seek data and this is
the heat map in the middle so the red
and blue to the left actually represents
the single cell original data and the
plots to the right actually represents
the sort itself that we pulled out based
on the cell surface markers and we
sequence those to make sure that we
actually recapitulating the same the
same cellular states that were
associated either with response or lack
of response
then we perform additional types of
analysis and we ask ourselves which of
those two cell states are important for
the tumour eradication in response to
checkpoint therapy in this case suppose
P d1 therapy and so we pulled out those
cells and perform a series of analysis
and Russ will elaborate more about the
microfluidic system the way that we
approach that we use in order to see
which one of those seller states is more
important for tumour medication we also
perform some in vivo experiments so then
I think about the single-cell RNA seek
that I doesn't also let us recognize
cells that are either associated with
response or lack of responses actually
let us know what are the markers that
are highly expressed in non-responding
tumors and then we can find new
combinations to therapy and this is what
we actually did with the in vivo
experiments based on the human data we
identify a set of targets that are
expressed on the cell surface so it is
it to target them and then we saw which
combinations are most significant
regional responding tumors and then we
verify that we see the same things in
mouse model tumors and then we performed
a dual targeting and we saw that by dual
targeting those targets but that were
undefined in an unbiased manner in the
human data can actually enable us to
Licht better clinical outcomes in in
vivo mouse models in terms of the
response of the tumors and also in the
survival of the mouse
Thank You Moshe so to talk a little bit
more about some of the functional
validation studies we did I'll give a
little bit of background on some of the
work that we do in our group which
essentially is creating a window into
the tumor immune micro environment and
that's the the murine derives or patient
derived organo tipic tumor spheroid
model or m dots or p dots for short so
just by way of a little bit of
background we get fresh never frozen
mouth tumors or patient tumors they're
subjected to physical and enzymatic
dissociation and then passed over
filters to get different sized
multicellular tumor spheroids
we've lots of experience and data
showing that the immune context chair of
these different size fractions not very
creatively named s1 s2 and s3 such a
greater than 100 micron 40 to 100 micron
or less than 40 micron don't differ
significantly and from the baseline
tumor and because they're optimally
sized we take the s2 fraction which
measures 40 to 100 micron based by size
selection and we inject that into a
microfluidic chamber so that they can be
cultured in the collagen hydrogel for
short term ex vivo profiling and we can
read out a variety of things on the back
end of this experiment including whether
there's a mute immediate killing
production of cytokines or transcript
changes for this talk we'll look
discussed mostly the X fetal killing and
I'll walk you through a little bit of
the workflow here so we start off with
the tumour it gets minced and we end up
with a mixture of these different
multicellular tumour spheroids and then
as I mentioned before we end up with
these different size through attractions
we take the specific fraction and
ranging in size from 40 to 100 microns
it gets embedded in a collagen hydrogel
that gets injected into the microfluidic
device and you have a picture of what
that looks like under the light
microscope at day zero and then it gets
treated usually with an anti pd-1
antibody or some other combination
treatment and we read out those
different things on the back end so very
quickly I wanted to just show a video a
cartoon of what this looks like in the
microfluidic device so we can see here
in this animation a standard
microfluidic device with the center gel
region flanked by anti parallel media
channels so the spheroids is a cells the
tumor cells immune cells are in these
multicellular tumor spheroids in this
Center gel region suspended in just a
couple microliters of collagen after
they've invaded for about 30 minutes at
37 degrees we hydrate these devices with
media containing either an antibody
isotype control like an IgG antibody an
anti pd-1 antibody or for combination
treatments you can add a small molecule
or targeted therapy and then we can
observe the response of the tumor immune
micro environment over time in a given
microfluidic device
this is what it looks like under the
microscope you start off with spheroids
add a zero and you can see that they
grow very nicely and robustly over time
this is the MSE 38 very immune
responsive syn genetic model we can
again sample the conditioned media and
look for two created cytokine changes we
can look at the immune context Revilla
mutants progressive as well so again
just to provide the background for how
we did the study with Moshe I'll talk a
little bit more about some of our proof
of principle studies where we took this
immune competence pd-1 responses NC 38
and genetic model which has very nice in
vivo response to single agent PD one
blockade shown on the far left and we
actually challenged it outside of the
mouth with a pv one antibody and this is
our workflow to do that where we get the
tumor we make our m dot some when we
load parallel microfluidic devices and
treat them either with an ISO type IgG
control or a PT one neutralizing
antibody and we have an ex vivo culture
for three to six days and then perform a
simple life debt assay with acridine
orange propidium iodide so this is what
it looks like when the spheroids not the
- or - you with the PD one neutralizing
antibody and it's insensitive to genetic
model use the accumulation of the
propidium iodide red signal and a loss
of the acridine orange live signal and
we can zoom in on an individual spheroid
and capture that a little bit better and
shown below is the very pd-1 resistant
be 16 f10 model
so harkening back to what moshe a spoke
about not too long ago how do we use
this sort of system for functional
testing and we had a system and a
wonderful data that Moshe described
where we have these different
populations of cd8 t-cells
that we think are responsible for
driving response or non-response to PD
one blockade so we discussed a way that
we could do this using a functional
assay in the microfluidic chip so in
designing this validation study we
wanted to pick a model system that was
partially responsive but not fully
responsive and we needed to be able to
characterize that we had both the cd8
good guys and the cd8 bad guys again the
effector memory type versus the severely
dysfunctional exhausted type sort them
out and then be able to enrich in the
microcytic device either with pure
populations or mixed populations
so for our first proof of principle
study we simply characterized that
within a partially sensitive mouse model
here was the CT 26 expressing a GFP
marker model at 14 days that we have a
nice mix of the cd39 Tim 3 double
positive up in the upper right quadrant
here so double positive or DT these are
the cd8 bad guys and then in the lower
left quadrant we have the double
negative cd39 negative Tim 3 negative
cd8 good guys we have a nice mixture of
these different populations shown on the
right by immunofluorescence is what
these tumors spheroids look like under
native conditions on the middle panel
where we see our GFP standing tumor
cells versus our cd8 cells and red
versus commission where we essentially
spiked into the device additional cd8
t-cells and an unselected fashion
so for the workflow for the experiment
to test whether the CDA good guys or bad
guys are modifying that response to PD
one blockade we set up the following
experimental design where tumors are
grown in mice we take them out we
generate em dots from them but at the
same time we take the unused proportions
the s 1 and s 3 fraction from the
original tumor prep and then we do cell
sorting based on the expression of CD 3
CD 8 to get make sure that we've got our
T cells and then to look by expression
of those exhaustion markers cd39 Tim 3
to get either a double negative
population a double positive population
and we preserve some of the extras so
that we can mix them in the one-to-one
fashion and then they're treated into
the micro flow device either with an iso
type control IgG antibody or a PD one
neutralizing antibody cultured for five
days and then we assess immune mediated
killing on day five so I'll walk you
through the bottom panel here which
essentially tells the tale so on the far
left of this graph entitled T key 26 GFP
M dots we see the conditions the pd-1
neutralizing antibody on the far left
where we get modest immune mediated
killing with PD 1 blockade this is
consistent with this particular model
system if we enriched a hundredfold the
number of cd8 T cells but they're
remixed in an equal proportion the good
guys and the bad guys we don't move the
needle at all
essentially it's as if we have added no
additional cd8 T cells
if instead we add the double negative or
cd8 good guy T cells all sudden we are
able to really improve upon the immune
mediated killing in response to PD one
blockade importantly these cells are not
actually killing the tumor cells in the
absence of pd-1 blockade so simply
enriching for cd8 ESO on its own is not
doing anything to the tumor however and
interestingly if we add the double
positive the cd39 positive Tim 3
positive cd8 t-cells the bad guys not
only do we not enhance killing but we
actually blunt the killing that was
observed in the unperturbed native
conditions this did point two and
actually I think confirmed the suspicion
that the balance between these two cd8
t-cell states was really important for
driving immune mediated killing so
before we move out and this presentation
part I do want to say a few words of pdx
models and single cella RNA sequencing
that actually things that accelerated in
recent years so PDX models is those who
do not know these are patient drive
photographs these are tumors that are
extracted from patients they are
injected to immune deficient mice these
tumor growth usually people test those
PD X's in the context of target therapy
and then when people start to
characterize those tumors what's
actually out the drug effect those tumor
cells what people usually do to just
extract the PDX tumors they either use
the place-based method bulk RNA seek
data or micro fluidic systems like the
10x genomic platforms and then sequence
the tumors and then you get those nice
stiff applause you get the distribution
of cells and stay tuned and sometimes or
in most cases people have the wrong
conclusions and the reason for that is
that those PD X's when we look at their
compositions within those immune
deficient mice so we think okay there's
no immune system so all the cells that
we have there are actually tumor cells
so we are looking at this and in most
cases this is a wrong assumption and the
reason that I'm saying that because we
had this issue and we had a very large
PDF say a study when we did those type
of analysis and then we started seeing
strange things things that are not
related we know that are not related to
the tumor cells and then when we started
looking what could be the reason we
started kind of typically characterizing
those PDX tumors and if you look at the
lower plots the far left one actually
shows you a pity X model that the
composition of cd45 negative cells is
less than 30% and in a a in a good tumor
we have it
a fraction of 70% meaning that we have a
30% contamination in addition to that
when we look at the human market of
those tumors in this case these are
epithelial tumors and we see that we can
enrich for those specific cells if we
want to and especially the thing that we
actually need to do and one thing that I
want to emphasize about those pdx model
or combining PDX models with single-cell
RNA sequencing or bulk RNA sequencing in
response to treatment is first - the
first step is actually to exclude the
Mouse host immune cells by performing
these types of gaining strategies
because again the purity is usually low
is usually around 40 to 50 percent and
on top of excluding this immune host
immune cells and other stromal cells is
actually the uses of markers of human
markets that we know there are expressed
on those tumors and then we pretty much
make sure that the cells that we extract
for the sequencing are actually the
tumor cells that we targeted in vivo
using different drugs and that actually
and I think improves the data and the
interpretation and the things that we
see using those PDX and mouse models to
conclude or to summarize what we've both
Russ and me have talked about today so
the usage of multi-omics approaches or
including unbiased approaches is to
really understand what's happening in
the setting of human and malignancies
and especially in the context of
checkpoint therapies so as I mentioned
earlier these studies are usually broken
into two steps we have this discovery
step that we actually enter to the area
in an unbiased manner we don't have any
hypotheses we look at we collect the
right code of patients to answer those
questions we perform those unbiased
analyses we identify cellular states
single genes that are associated with
response or lack of response based on
those discoveries we start building our
hypotheses and then we check them either
using
new and innovative 3d microfluidic
system that can actually recapitulate
the in vivo micro environments or using
in vivo mouse models and other
experimental approaches to answer those
questions
finally and I think both of us would
like to actually acknowledge a lot of
people that helped us and do this types
of analysis the clinicians of course at
Mass General and MD Anderson people in
the labs that we've been working other
collaborators that their names are
presented here at the end and thank you
for listening and now we'll be more than
happy to answer any questions that you
have
Thank You dr. Feldman and dr. Jenkins
for your informative presentations we
will now be pushing out a survey to the
audience that will pop up on your screen
we will give you a moment to answer this
we appreciate your participation
okay we will now move on and start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for pay let's get started our
first question is if most mutations in
neoplastic cells affect intracellular
replicative machinery of the cell while
you system recognized only membrane
abnormal antigens how did the mutation
burden how does the mutation burden
correlate with immunity of cancer cells
and that's a very interesting question
that I would like to answer so
regardless of what pathway is being and
changed due to the specific mutations or
mutations especially when we talk about
melanoma that has one of the highest
mutation rate so every mutation that
occurs within a given cell and we have a
mute that leads to a mutated protein or
product it's being degraded through the
immuno proteasome and eventually it's
being and presented through plus one and
molecules on the cell surface of the
cells and within those mutated proteins
or peptides that are eventually being
presented on the cell surface the more
mutation a given cell will have the
higher probability that this peptide or
new antigen that was specifically
mutated in the cancer cell will be
recognized by an immune cells so that
has nothing to do with actually what
pathway is being changed or what protein
is being changed inside the given cells
could be things that again as mentioned
related to cell proliferation growth and
other factors that can enhance the
motility of cells it has literally and
to do with the how many antigens are
eventually presented and it has nothing
to do with what type of protein is being
mutated because all those proteins are
eventually being presented on the class
1 and molecule on the sole surfers so
again the more mutations the higher
probability that this mutation will
eventually be recognized by a by an
immune cell is higher so the higher the
TMB the higher the probability that
there will be an immune recognition and
then eventually a better prediction or
for clinical outcomes
great thank you all right next question
how do you know that the mouse is an
appropriate model to test the drugs
very very good question so this is I
think a problem that a lot of people
encounter when if they think they have a
new exciting interesting target and
they're interested in finding out in
particular if there's an interaction
with the immune system I will say that a
lot of the the novel immunotherapy
started out in mouse model system so I
think it's a very reasonable starting
point if there's a novel checkpoint or
another immune modulator to start off in
a murine model system exactly which
model system gets a little more
complicated as you know when Moshe and I
were working together we picked kind of
a partially sensitive model system with
the hypothesis that the different cd8
t-cell States would both be represented
and we had no data we just had to kind
of pick a model system and try and so I
think that's a reasonable place to start
now some of the model systems are more
immunogenic more responses some are less
immunogenic less responsive I think one
just has to kind of you know pour over
the literature figure out what other
people doing see if the target they're
interested in exploring is one that
might be more active in one a model
system versus another and then just do
the experiment I think one of the
advantages of doing ex vivo profiling is
if one has a hypothesis that a
particular drug or target is going to be
potentially more active in a model tumor
immune micro environment that you can
take a handful of tumors tumor x plants
and actually do the experiment ex vivo
in the microfluidic culture system as
opposed to having to go to straight to
in vivo where you don't necessarily know
exactly how to start what to start or if
there's going to be single agent or
combination efficacy but I'd say Mouse
systems are still informative they do
teach us things the fact that in mosha
is data they which was all human patient
samples they identified these discrete
cell states these discrete cd8 t-cell
States and those same states were were
also recovered
mouth system and several other groups
have subsequently published similar
findings in urine systems does point
that there will be some conservation
across species but ultimately one just
needs to test the hypothesis I think
great thank you all right next question
how do you know that the SB analysis is
superior I would expect the harsh that
harsh separation of cells within itself
cause changes that are not natural but
stress response so first of all I have
to say that I do agree with this so if
we take if we take a given tissue that's
composed of different cells and then you
know cells interact with each other and
when we start isolating specific cells
and try to you know ask questions how is
their phenotype being affected ex vivo
or - given stimulation so yes we do not
take into account or we cannot take into
account that the effects of other
neighboring cells and yes that actually
does change the cell phenotype in our
case however when we did the single cell
sorting we did it immediately into a
lysis buffer so we took a given tissue
we dissociate the cells but all given
cells were still inside it you mix
together or condense together and then
when we sorted the cells we saw them
immediately into lysis buffer regarding
and you know future studies or other
things that we are doing yes these
things needs to be taking into account
when you isolate cells so you need to
take into account that their phenotype
might change so the way that we try to
tackle this approach so for instance
when we do a more pointed analysis on
specific cell population we isolate the
cells we perform the single cell RNA
sequencing but we also do a bulk on
another bulk we we take the entire
tissue and perform this type of analysis
as well and then we can identify those
specific population within the giving
tissue and we compare the two
populations the ones that are in its
natural state in the whole tissue how
those cells let's say if we talk about
specific T cells and how those cells
phenotype Luke when we isolated them and
I have to say that in most cases when we
do this thing relatively rapidly we
don't see any differences I hope that
that answered that the
question
thank you okay do you think that invivo
might appear fusion between the elastic
cell normal cell or even neoplastic cell
immune cell similar to the hybrid ohm
process
a moment to review the question one more
time
so I want to make sure I understand the
question so if I understand it so do we
think that in vivo might represent some
sort of interaction between the cancer
cell and the non transform cancer cell
or the cancer cell
normal cell versus cancer cell and mewn
cell too much a hybridoma process I'm
not sure I fully understand the question
so I don't want to speculate too too
much
yeah I'm going to have to say that I
appreciate the question but I might need
it revised from our Inquirer I'm not
sure I fully understand the question and
how that relates to a hybridoma process
I apologize
sure and we can always follow up with
that question after the broadcast and
we'll follow up with you via email all
right next question
how are the fell from the patient tumor
process to prepare cell suspension them
for cell sorting
can you please repeat the question sure
how are the cells from the patient tumor
process to prepare cell suspension for
cell sorting
and okay so that's actually a very good
and important question and that can
actually affect the downstream analysis
and quality of yourself so we're
actually applied or modified a little
bit than the Milton II a to more
dissociation kit so we are using those
reagents inside the kit which are very
good they're very gentle on the cells
they do not remove cell surface markers
that other conventional digestion
reagents do which is important if you
want to incorporate antibody labeling to
your single cell and one thing that we
did do and adjust it to our method and
we tested it Co on several times and we
compared the results that we had was
want to reduce the time of dissociation
instead of doing the dissociation for 45
minutes we're doing the dissociation for
15 to 20 minutes we also change the way
that we do the dissociation so if you go
through the Milton E and to me
dissociation keep protocol you'll see
that they're using the C tubes the C
tubes are tubes that enable both
enzymatic and mechanical digestion at
the same time so but the problem is that
sometimes when you get really small
biopsies or needle core boxes which are
very tiny or put the biopsy inside I'll
probably lose most of myself there so
what we adopted we're actually using
eppendorf tubes that we cut the tissue
inside the tube we added as I make sure
the same ratios and then we do the
dissociation using a thermo mixer and
37° again for 15 to 20 minutes and I
think there's a really importance for
how long your dissociation is being done
because we do want to exclude as many
artifacts that are being generated by
the dissociation itself so we minimize
the time from 45 minutes to 15 to 20
minutes and in the paper that we
published there's actually a very
detailed explanation for the time
duration and
situation on all the relevant catalog
numbers and that can annotate for this
specific procedure
great thank you how do you take care of
the extracted T cells for storage and
shipment
and so for that we're using actually a
conventional frizzing media which is
usually a 90% therm heating activated
servant 10% DM so we tend not to freeze
a low number of cells as these are you
know when we told this also the problem
is that you lose number you can
sometimes is somewhere between 30 to 50
percent of your cells when you throw
them so don't freeze a very few cells
I recommend freezing amounts ranging
from half a million to two to three
million per tube in one ml of freezing
media in terms for shipment so when we
do this type of shipments between labs
or collaborators we usually ship those
on dry ice and the cells themselves
they're stored at the beginning at minus
eighty but then for longer storage
periods we store the cells in liquid
nitrogen
are there any tips you can share to
improve smart seek - results on single
cells
actually I do and getting to exactly
that you know that the detailed reagents
and procedure these are all publicly
available in the paper that we published
is actually a supplementary table that
the last suplementario table in our
paper actually has a very detailed on
what reagents we used and exactly the
temperature for each true step reaction
that we did and one thing that i noticed
recently that people when they do smart
sig - and that's an issue that i've
encountered with collaborators a
sometimes they take the protocol from a
given paper and they use a reverse
transcribe enzyme which is different
from the ones that is was being used or
was not adjusted to the temperatures so
the most common that's the most common
error that we do see so i highly
recommend if you are changing your RT
enzyme just make sure that you're using
the temperature that this enzyme was in
it can work efficiently for instance the
maxima enzyme which that's the enzyme
that we are using that's a very cost
effective one it works best at 50
degrees and when we talk to a lot of
collaborators that had those issues we
actually notice that they've been using
the old protocols and worked at 42
degrees another two tips that I can give
just to increase the quality of the
cells and this is something that we've
been noticing since we have a lot of
experience with that it's first work as
fast as you can with the first steps
minimize the time for tissue
dissociation make sure that your gating
strategy is correct excluding dead cells
and cells that are and use that you are
sorting the cells that you a desire and
I think the example that I gave was with
the CD 2 3 5 a that exclude a russified
progenitors that sometimes people
mistake for being the tumor cells and so
the two critical steps are actually this
is the tissue dissociation the quality
of the sorting
and from there it's just going by the
protocol for a RNA extraction extraction
cleanups and cDNA and amplification and
so forth but those two steps we've found
to be the most crucial ones
great thank you it looks like we have
time for a few more what is the best
approach to increase the efficiency of
plate sorting when using patient sample
okay so the especially with the sounding
cell sorter so this is where we had all
our experience so when you go to the
default plate sorting so this actually
gives you an error over 20% and what it
means that if we look at the droplet
that contains one cell for single cell
sorting if the cell is in the center of
this drop droplet and and when we use
the default settings it means that it
can move from the center 20% up 20% down
but not more than that so if this cell
if the Machine identified the cell not
to be exactly at the center of the drop
or with a deviation of 20 percent it
will export and once or the the sample
one thing that we've been doing we've
been we increased a little bit distress
hold we did this like as a custom and
sorting to 60% so this range actually
enables more flexibility to increase the
yield of how many cells are actually
being sorted into the plate and still
without losing the quality meaning there
is still a 1 cell in a droplet the soul
are relatively small to the droplet size
so it is even within this 60 percent
deviation up and down we can still
capture the right cells and increase the
yields of the cell sorting and again
another thing as I mentioned the
previous question is again work fast on
the disassociation start the sorting is
once once you're done minimize the times
in between and and and that's it pretty
much
great thank you it looks like we have
time for one last question how should we
balance the performance parameters when
conducting cell sorting experiments such
as yield efficiency purity
so that's actually a good question and
it relates to the question that I
answered before so there's the custom
setting as I mentioned so you can
actually change that and increase the
distribution of a cell in a given
droplet to give it more flexibility to
capture more that's actually increases
the yield without actually affecting
there the purity of the populations if
there is a population that's very rare
and your sample is super necrotic so I
would highly recommend using the super
purity mode that make sure that you know
droplets above and below that the this
this sorted cell are empty there's
nothing there so that actually very
increases the the purity but then again
it comes on the price of the yield so
sometimes you know if you don't want to
lose your precious sample especially if
this cell is yield is very low and you
know it's a give and take right so how
much am i putting or the purity and how
much am i putting on the hill so
sometimes we need to compromise and but
that's a great thing about single-cell
RNA sequencing because since we are
sorting single cells into individual
wells and eventually we do analyze
single cells we can actually know if we
sorted the right or wrong cell and I
hope the depth and say and answer the
question
thank you again dr. Feldman and dr.
Jenkins for your time today in your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor stony
biotechnology for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye